on va se tourner vers jean-marc
jancovici vous êtes associé et co
fondateur du cabinet de conseil qui
s'appelle carbone 4 vous vous définissez
comme un praticien de la décarbonation
et vous êtes aussi le enseignants à
mines paristech et président fondateur
d'un spectacle qui s'appelle le shift
project sur les politiques de la
transition est justement ce chiffre
project a émis 9 propositions très
concrètes pour les carbonées l'économie
à l'as que voudriez nous les présentait
bien volontiers alors je vais comme tout
consultants qui se respecte avoir un
travers c'est que j'ai préparé les
supports parce qu'un consultant qui ne
fait pas de slide à ce suicide c'est
plus rien et la deuxième chose c'est que
nonobstant le fait que je sorte
également de cet endroit où j'ai de bons
souvenirs je vais essayer de me
contenter de quelques règle de trois est
un peu de bon sens alors le break de
trois et un peu de bon sens c'est que si
on veut faire baisser les émissions il
vaut mieux savoir où sont les émissions
est ce que je vous présente ici c'est le
panorama des émissions européennes alors
quoi j'ai pris l'europe et à la france
parce que en matière d'environnement
l'essentiel de la compétence et
européennes il faut quand même se le
rappeler du reste la france a tendance à
l'oublier un peu trop souvent que c'est
pas inutile d'aller faire un tour du
côté de la commission quand on a des
sujets environnementaux à faire avancer
dans le camembert que vous voyez là il
ya quelque chose ensemble qui sont des
gros sous ensembles alors dans la
production électrique
on a un gros sous ensembles s'appelle
les centrales à charbon en europe et les
centrales à charbon c'est 20% des
émissions européennes à elle toute seule
ensuite on a un deuxième gros sous
ensembles dans les transports qui sont
les voitures une voiture particulière
fanti % des émissions elle toute seule
ensuite dans les émissions industrielles
vous avez un gros sous ensembles qui la
production des matériaux de base donc
l'acier le ciment les produits chimiques
de base etc et enfin dans l'agriculture
vous avez un gros sous ensembles qui est
le cheptel bovin
alors si on veut que les émissions
deviennent nul et soit à court terme
donc / n'importe quoi entre 1 et 10
c'est très compliqué de faire ça en
s'intéressant juste au trombone faut
aller taper dans le dur c'est-à-dire là
où est le gros des émissions donc le
shift a réfléchi à des propositions
moins de 10 on a même fait neuf pour que
ça fasse un carré parfait
c'est plus pratique pour les
présentations et on a réfléchi à ce
qu'on pouvait proposer comme mesure
qu'on considère incontournable c'est à
dire si on ne touche pas aux centrales à
charbon dans la production électrique on
peut rajouter tous les panneaux solaires
qu'on veut on n'a rien fait d'accord
c'est ce que disait si on ne touche pas
aux voitures dans les transports on n'a
rien vu voilà on traitera jamais mesuré
alors les les mesures sur lesquelles on
s'est dit ça c'est un socle de base
donc c'est un tarif minimum price tag
le premier c'est de sortir le charbon en
europe dans les 30 ans qui viennent
donc il faut que y est plus une centrale
à charbon en europe dans les 30 ans qui
viennent donc je suis sûr que je voulais
passer notre ami polonais ils voient la
ilaha illa il a pâli sortie soit dit en
passant il suffit pas de mettre un prix
sur le charbon pour faire ça parce que
si ma mémoire est bonne il ya pas loin
de cent mille personnes en pologne qui
vivent de l'industrie du charbon et donc
leur première question c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ces gens là donc je suis tout
à fait pour qu'on dise qu'on va
supprimer des centrales à charbon
mais tant qu'on n'a rien dit sur
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des cent mille
personnes qui en vivent on n'avance pas
c'est absolument évident on a deux armes
possibles pour faire ça l'une d'elles
est techniquement c'est le prix donc on
dit on va monter le prix du co2 puis à
un moment les centrales à charbon
meurent de leur belle mort
mais donc il faut savoir encore une fois
comment on traite les perdants l'autre
alternative est une voie réglementaire
on peut très bien dire c'est celle que
pour un sujet qui pour moi est
malheureux puisque c'est justement le
truc qui ne faut pas faire mais qui est
la fermeture de capacités nucléaires les
états choisissent une voie réglementaire
qui disent pas on va monter le prix du
nucléaire ils ferment encore une fois
c'est le truc qui pour moi est une
bêtise mais ça montre que la voie
réglementaire ça marche aussi et en
europe on pourrait très bien dire les
capacités au charbon on les ferme à
telle date
d'accord aux etats unis l'administration
américaine a dit il est interdit de
construire une nouvelle capacité
électrique de plus ce qui fait plus de
unes livre de co2 par kilowattheure ça
interdit de fait de remplacer une
centrale à charbon par une centrale à
charbon de fait
deuxième sujet en ce qui concerne la
mobilité il ya une arme à bruxelles qui
s'appelle la réglementation des
véhicules neufs vendus
c'est beaucoup plus rapide à activer que
monter le prix du carburant il se passe
que la rotation du parc se fait en vingt
ans donc si vous dites en 2030 on ne
vend plus une voiture qui fait plus de
deux litres aux 100 en 2050 vous n'avez
plus une voiture qui circule qui fait
plus de deux litres aux cent alors les
deux litres vous pouvez les ajuster un
litre et demi d'eau
on fera des deux chevaux d'entrée grave
j'ai appris à conduire dans une deux
choses les mêmes gars est un endroit où
j'aurais pas dû ici j'ai eu un
autocollant sur le pare brise et donc et
c'était une très bonne chose que j'en ai
eu un ça m'a appris la vie met donc on
peut très bien utiliser la voie
réglementaire on peut aussi utiliser une
voie fiscale mais qui n'est pas un prix
du carbone qui était la vignette qui
soit dit en passant pour la petite
histoire a été supprimée par le
président de la cap 21
quand il était premier ministre monsieur
fabius la vignette c'est donc un impôt à
la détention
donc vous payez chaque est c'est un
malus annuel quoi et c'est un truc qui
peut être parfaitement progressif
si vous êtes pauvre et que vous avez
besoin du deux chevaux pour aller au
travail vous avez un truc nul ou très
faible et puis si vous avez plus que ça
quand vous 10 et 20 cm c'est un élément
de confort ouf on matraque vous avez un
autre sujet qui est que le gilet jaune
si vous montez prix du carburant il n'a
pas les moyens de se payer une voiture
neuve qui consomment moins ils à vous
allez déprécier sa voiture d'occasion
parce que on dit du coup elle consomme
trop et sa valeur sur le marché et c'est
donc qu'est-ce qui fait il va pas faire
20 km en voiture plutôt que de faire les
25 ans voiture est terminée à pied c'est
sûr qu'il va pas faire ça donc ça veut
dire aussi qu'il ya une planification
des alternatives à faire par la société
et en matière de transports la montée du
prix du carburant laquelle je suis
favorable est un codicille d'une
planification d'ensemble ça ne peut pas
être un instrument principal parce que
sinon vous mettez les gens dans une
situation de corner et à ce moment les
gens se révoltent donc c'est un
codicille c'est pas un instrument
principal pour moi il faut par ailleurs
planifier les reports modaux et avoir
soit des investissements comme le disait
benoît soit des systèmes
organisationnels soit des systèmes
culturels comme le disait tout à l'heure
valérie c'est à dire qu'on considère que
c'est pas grave si on a un vélo plutôt
qu'une voiture en termes de statut
social voilà il ya un certain nombre de
choses sur lesquelles il faut qu'on il
faut qu'on travaille dans un monde à
zéro émission il ya un sujet qui va
avoir une industrie c'est dommage parce
que ça fait beaucoup de pib en france
mais qui va avoir un vrai problème
appel de transport aérien parce que
faire transport le faire voler des
avions électriques monsieur picard sait
faire ça avec un passager ça vole à la
vitesse d'une mobylette et quand vous
regardez les émissions de co2 qui sont
incluses dans le vol au travers de toute
la r&d amont qu'il a fallu faire ça
consomme 100 fois plus de carburant aux
100 kilomètres qui a un avion de ligne
par passager donc c'est pas un truc qui
va remplacer les a380 c'est sûr mais
quand il aura plus de pétrole
quand on décidera de ne plus en
consommer y restera éventuellement le
vingtième du trafic aérien qui a
aujourd'hui où le 40e avec quelques
biocarburants pas beaucoup et donc il
faudra quand même assurer les transports
un peu longue distance donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut réinvestir d'entrain ça c'est
pareil c'est pas un sujet uniquement de
signal prix c'est pas en montant le prix
du carburant que vous allez déclencher
les investissements publics parce que
c'est essentiellement des
investissements publics dans les
infrastructures ferroviaires ce parce
que vous décidez de le faire après en ce
qui concerne l'industrie lourde
là c'est un domaine dans lequel le
signal-prix marche bien mais il faut
accepter de faire des perdants donc là
c'est clair que si vous avez parce que
le 'b to b' réfléchit beaucoup plus à
l'avenir économique que le consommateur
alors nous on n'est pas des animaux
rationnelle en tant que consommateur en
tant que ménages par contre quand je
suis à mon bureau entre 8h du matin et
tard le soir là il est évident que je
deviens un animal beaucoup plus
rationnelle et je fais des calculs donc
le signal prix ça marche beaucoup mieux
dans le 'b to b' que dans le beat ou six
ans si elle court j'ai envie de dire btu
si ça marche mais en signal beaucoup
plus long donc dans l'industrie lourde
en gros il faut diviser les volumes
produits par 3,4
c'est à peu près ça l'enjeu donc il faut
faire trois fois moins de ciment trois
fois moins d'acier transforme en
plastique etc
et là on va pas y arriver à mon avis
juste avec un signal prix ça va être un
peu plus compliqué que ça en ce qui
concerne les bâtiments là c'est très
simple il faut passer par des signaux
réglementaires de mon point de vue c'est
à dire que c'est pas en disant aux
consommateurs que le fioul et le gaz
vont augmenter qu'il va faire les bons
investissements à temps il faut obliger
un exemple vous avez des ravalements
d'immeubles dans ce pays et bien il doit
plus y en avoir un qui est fait sans
qu'on fasse une isolation par
l'extérieur sauf contrainte
architectural majeur voilà mais si l'on
est obligatoire on vous demande pas
votre avis à partir de 2022 il est
interdit de remplacer une chaudière à
fuel par une autre chaudière à fuel
voilà ça on vous dit pas le fioul va
monter et c'est assez juste interdit
après la bonne question comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure par jean tirole sait
comment vous compenser les perdants
ça c'est une bonne question mais si vous
passez par la voie réglementaire ça va
beaucoup plus vite que de passer par la
voie prix l'investissement public dans
cette affaire est une manière de
déclencher l'investissement privé parce
que les gros parcs sont dans le public
le pavillon de banlieue de monsieur tout
le monde s'y intéresse pas bouygues et
eiffage
par contre si vous rénovez l'ap-hp ça ça
les intéresse donc l'investissement
public où l'école polytechnique soit dit
en passant donc l'investissement public
pardon l'investissement dans le secteur
public en matière de rénovation
c'est quelque chose qui vous tirent le
secteur parce que ça bouge les gros
enfin en ce qui concerne la filière bois
là c'est pareil pour quiconque à
regarder d'un peu près ce truc là c'est
l'univers professionnel en france qui a
la plus grande densité d'organismes
représentatif par euros de chiffre
d'affaires
c'est absolument hallucinant il doit y
avoir dix ou douze syndicats
professionnels dans ce truc là village
gaulois par excellence arriver à faire
des choses un peu significatif dans un
pays où vous avez 3 millions de
propriétaires forestiers juste avec le
signal-prix bon courage c'est évident là
aussi qu' il faut y aller par la voie
réglementaire pour l'essentiel et enfin
dernier point ce qui est si toujours on
est un peu cash
il faut organiser quelque chose qui
ressemble à une division par deux du
cheptel bovin en europe
mais comme les agriculteurs et les
éleveurs font un métier beaucoup plus
difficile que tous les gens qui sont
dans cette salle il n'y a pas de raison
de passer par un signal prix qu'ils
utiliseraient les quantités produites
par deux à prix constants payé aux
éleveurs parce que là bonjour les taux
de suicide
donc là ça veut dire qu'il faut encadrer
les prix est derrière vous avez de
nouveau un besoin d'un instrument
réglementaire qui est pas nécessairement
un prix du carbone serre si je fais
payer les émissions de méthane à mes
agriculteurs l'âge et les faits qui ne
m'intéresse pas j'en fait disparaître la
moitié avec les volumes divisé par deux
par contre si je mets de la
réglementation typiquement des normes
des aoc et labels etc contre un
encadrement des prix donc je leur dis
vous allez me faire que du bio aoc
machin etc
tout le monde va avoir les normes contée
par contre fromage
par contre je multiplie les prix par
deux ou trois eh bien vous avez un vous
êtes dans un système réglementaire avec
primé réglementaires ou la personne qui
doit directement faire des efforts n'est
pas acculé au suicide
voilà donc voilà si vous faites le total
de tous ces trucs là vous tapez dans une
grosse moitié des émissions européennes
c'est une autre manière de dire que
diviser les émissions par trois sans
toucher à ce truc là je ne suis pas
complètement sûr qu'on va y arriver
merci beaucoup jean marc jancovici alors